ramping up to do that scene for like
three years
filming got off to a rocky start the
crew got stranded on an island and
robert pattinson crashed a boat could
have been better the fourth film in the
twilight franchise required a lot of
work and some tight security to make
sure the production went off without a
hitch kristen stewart even had to cover
her wedding dress with a cape whenever
she wasn't filming it's a good disguise
which producer makes a sneaky appearance
in the movie
filming in brazil brought the cast and
crew of breaking dawn part one a fair
amount of troubles
particularly when it came to filming on
an island the team was just three days
into filming on location in south
america when they wound up being
stranded on a small island overnight
because of extremely bad weather the
crew acted quickly and tarps were
brought out to protect the cast from
getting too wet and the set pieces from
becoming damaged since filming abroad
proved to be tricky especially with
having only one week in brazil the
majority of the set was recreated in
louisiana to fill most of the indoor
honeymoon shots with cgi added after the
fact
bella and edward's wedding was a pretty
big deal
and it was saved to be the last scene
filmed with major security precautions
taken
there were literally helicopters
overhead making sure no one could see
what was going on except for those
involved with the production on the
ground blankets and umbrellas were used
to keep the set and cast out of sight
christian stewart was even sporting a
cape when the cameras stopped rolling to
avoid any leaked images of the
custom-made wedding dress just to make
sure everything was extra secure there
were also literal police officers
surrounding the scene
running at incredible speed for the
camera wasn't just a result of training
elizabeth reeser and kellen lutz were
actually set in a pretty precarious rig
with a rolling treadmill the actors were
secured on the rig by this green beam
while it was also being pulled by a
truck with cameras hooked up to it
capturing all the action
filming in a gorgeous country like
brazil might seem like a dream but for
robert pattinson one scary shooting day
was a real life nightmare the actor was
manning a boat in the water but instead
of smooth sailing pattinson wound up
crashing the rig
to make it all worse it wasn't a private
affair the edward cullen actor had 5 000
pairs of eyes watching on the upside the
actor was already pretty used to
crashing the boat since he had regularly
done so when he was taking boating
lessons evidently it seems like he could
have used a few more lessons
kristen stewart and robert pattinson had
to get very intimate for the cameras on
numerous occasions
but what they hadn't planned for was
needing to reshoot their climactic
intimate scene initially the footage
captured was way too risque and required
the film to have an r rating but with so
many fans of the franchise being younger
the team opted to go to camera again the
major issue
too much of pattinson's rear end was
featured also you used to be able to see
my butt in it while it was a tough scene
for kristen stewart to do she was happy
with it in the end even though it was
just 40 seconds long in the final cut
watching bella give birth and breaking
dawn part 1 is still a traumatizing
experience and unfortunately it wasn't
much better on set for the cast and crew
pattinson even called it perhaps the
ickiest birth scene ever filmed it's not
a fun one to watch with all the gory
details and bella's clearly intense pain
with her already being in such a tough
state sickly and severely underweight
the scene is far from pleasant
the birth scene may be disturbing but
credit has to be given to the team for
how creative they got when it came to
bringing the moment to life the creepy
blood on newborn renesme was actually a
combination of strawberry jam and cream
cheese we can only imagine it would have
been a very sticky situation for
everyone involved
three hours worth of makeup and
prosthetics were applied to christian
stewart for her birthing scene
surprisingly much of what we see of
stewart's body is actually prosthetics
pretty much from the shoulders down
the large table she was laying on had a
space in it so the actress could lay her
body down underneath the prosthetics she
wasn't alone under the table though a
puppeteer was based inside to maneuver
the limbs realistically
kellen lutz put his down time to
extremely productive use while shooting
the final two twilight films
between takes the actor went workout
crazy and was getting fit consistently
for the full seven months of filming
resulting in a very buff body lutz made
very good use of all that down time
while taylor lautner was famously
topless throughout the majority of the
twilight saga
isn't he on a shirt robert pattinson had
his fair share of shirtless moments
especially when edward and bella filmed
some of their spiciest and most intimate
scenes in breaking dawn part 1. the
actor spent a full 6 months doing
intense training and watching his diet
before filming
because it's the only one i really
worked out for all of which ended once
the intimate scene had finished filming
so many of the male actors in twilight
seemed to be on intense workout and diet
regimens and lautner was of course no
exception all those shirtless scenes
required a lot of work behind the scenes
but for the actor the biggest challenge
was actually the amount of calories he
had to eat during his intense workout
times lautner was often sneaking bits of
food between takes to contribute to the
whopping 4 000 calories he had to eat
per day
pattinson really put a lot of effort and
work into his role as edward in fact he
learned to speak portuguese
just for the sake of shooting the scene
with the housekeepers when edward and
bella are on their honeymoon in brazil
he may be needing some more lessons
though
renesmee as a newborn shockingly wasn't
just a prop doll
there was a real infant on set depending
on what was being filmed the team
swapped the doll for the real child and
both had cgi retouching done and editing
performing with an infant is an intense
experience
working with a real baby isn't always
easy though especially when it's not
happy and screams to let everyone know
it
jacob's emotions in breaking down part
one go to a whole new level taylor
lautner really gave it his all when it
came to the twilight films so no doubt
he was invested in the final products
according to kristen stewart the jacob
actor actually cried while watching one
of the cuts with the cast with all the
work time and effort it's no surprise
lautner caught some feelings
it was it was tough when it came to an
end
the writer of the twilight books was
never too far being on set for all of
the filming and she actually made the
cut in a major scene amid the crowd
watching edward and bella getting
married is the author stephanie meyer
she the other screenwriter melissa
rosenberg and wic godfrey a producer got
to attend the wedding together
since meyer was one of the screenwriters
and executive producer and the creator
of the whole twilight universe she
definitely earned her cameo appearance
it had been a while since her first as a
restaurant customer in the first
twilight film
the cast and crew may have faced some
hurdles while filming especially when on
location and trying to keep the wedding
scene totally hidden but they pulled off
another great film
evidently these movies were a huge
commitment for much of the cast and crew
if we were stephanie meyer we'd want to
make cameos in the films as well